[Musique]
dans le gymnase de l'école charles
rodrigue aller vite
des élèves de première pratique leur
coordination en lançant un ballon sur le
lapin qui tient la bonne couleur
on la joue et garçons et des filles de
4e s'affrontent dans un duel de
mathématiques quand le ballon frappe la
bonne réponse
c'est un point pour l'équipe ça vous
aide à apprendre
j'aime vraiment les mathématiques jamais
accroché ce portier que ce soit pour des
tests d'endurance ou pour des séances de
relaxation
le système baptisé lui a transformé le
gymnase de l'école ordinaire de jeux
interactive et lui est entièrement conçu
et fabriqué ici à québec on installer
notre premier produit à peu près de 220
sert aussi à fabriquer le prototype peut
pas voir sa fille fasse son entrée à
l'école lorsqu'il a publié une vidéo du
résultat en ligne la demande a été
instantanée et les venues de partout
dans le monde
on est maintenant 24 personnes à temps
plein a travaillé sur le produit on en a
350 d'installer dans plus de 22 pays
[ __ ] salle explose littéralement la
majorité de ces unités là ont été
installés dans les dernières dans les 12
à 18 mois je vous dirais fait que c'est
vraiment une croissance une progression
un progrès sont super rapide 60 écoles
québécoises ont adopté le système dans
tout les jeux la dentition et qu'est ce
que j'aime dit j'ai aussi c'est que ça
nous apprend travail en équipe tout les
petits ballons mots c'est là où on a un
système qui est installée en ce moment
plusieurs modèles ont été installés sur
la côte est des états unis
le dernier exemplaire sortir de
l'assemblage est sur le point de partir
pour une école d'atlanta aux états unis
puis au canada un beau développement sur
la côte est qui on est en train de
percer de plus en plus sur la côte ouest
ce qu'on voit en europe on a quand même
une belle couverture pour l'allemagne la
france ont commencé à développer
l'angleterre qui
l'allemagne qui ont un très très bon
partenaire encore il sait lui est
composé d'un projecteur de caméra qui
détecte le mouvement d'un système
d'éclairage multicolores et de deux
caisses de son les applications cours
toutes sortes de matières en plus de
l'éducation physique
les élèves peuvent réviser leurs
connaissances en français en sciences en
géographie ou en mathématiques
donc ça permet aux enfants de réviser
exemple les tables d'addition de
soustraction un combinant un geste
moteur qui en battant le lancer de
précision lui coûte un peu moins de
20000 dollars
un investissement qui transforme le
gymnase on eu lieu d'apprentissage
ça fait un an qu'on l'utilisé très
apprécié les enfants le faire et on
utilise aussi à différents moments et on
peut mettre de la musique juste la
lumière pour des activités spéciales on
utilisait alors loin avec lui les
enfants bougent et apprennent un système
qui donne gymnase de l'école une toute
autre dimension
sa mise en oeuvre et du canada québec